come al sito il.topo come saluto
bravissinaa e spigliatissima
Oggi vi faccio vedere una nuova telenovela superfamosa
La cui il protagonista sono proprio jo
buena vision
amo non ti ho detto
eh dimmi.  Elena è incinta.  Di Giorgio?
Cosa c'è da scandalizzarsi sta insieme da una vita cioè sarebbe successo prima o poi no eh ho capito dai per fare un po di gossip suu
Mya cuci bauli spa robert sia della piega è... I N Z I N T A
Chi si è permesso di ingravidarla?
Coar carlos mag ha detto lui si può arrivare
solimena
Ma loro lo sanno che sono
F R A T E L L I
Ma sei pazza? Togli subito questa foto, sono oscena,  come ti è venuto in mente di mettere una foto del genere?
certo che ti perdono però toglila subito
Parlo con fosse fino a qua mita che mena olivares terzina
Come ti sei permesso di pubblicare quella mia foto oscena
Maria dolores per doman non. L'ho fatto apposta, se vuoi la cancello subito
Donna ci dovevi pensare prima, adesso mi incaricherò
Personalmente di rendere la tua vita ancora più miserabile
per sempre
Ma tu si intitola 0 salvo
No perché non mi ancora fatto gli auguri sempre le prima cioè ma sì infatti mi rifarò x dire
Tia maria carmen è forse haifa soledad consensi
Non dovevi farmi questo sono stata impegnata con. Il lavoro mi sono dimenticato
Lo sai che ti penso sempre per giornali se vuoi ti prego con una sola chiamata
Ti farò tornare ad essere la morta di fame che sei sempre
stato
Uomo diretto
In 3d con quel cesso adesso blocco l'odio
Juan francisco martin de la vega rodriguez all'imax
forse
espatri e nation
Io ti farò terra bruciata in tutto il paese
è un uomo che tradisce
il suo nome
ho fatto
Mamma mi sono fatto niente probabilmente a rimettere la cena abitami almeno scivolo
Dite abolito che è il mio figlio e che suo padre
giardiniere
quello fisicato però
È detto carlos che lo sa
nonostante l'abbia tradito con quattro uomini
Addio mondo crudele
Purtroppo ragazzi siamo giunti alla fine che questo video
fantastico e spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto e che vogliate una seconda puntata
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto qual è il vostro personaggio preferito di questa nuova telenovela
E se non. Lo avete ancora fatto. Gli script mette. Il canale attiva
Della campania che trova e vicino al tasto di iscrizione dai soprattutto seguitemi, su tutti gli altri social
facebook e news italia a loro